did you have a tip growing up or a dog
or anything um yeah I had some pets I
think my first pet was a guinea pig
Oh named carrot nice I like that ya know
dogs are on that dogs you did yeah
English bullmastiffs
mean Cupid er yeah yeah yeah and in this
dome you're ticking out like it's the
same the fight scenes are even stronger
than the first time around which I think
it was possible
yeah I'm trying thank you for trying to
kill yeah you cut but what would you say
is one of his weaknesses John Wick's
weakness hmm um you know I don't know if
he has a weakness but he's vulnerable I
mean he gets hurt he gets knocked down
and is hit by cars and drones or windows
but he he keeps coming back you know
he's got a strong will um I don't know
John which we need isn't Halloween I
have yet to be found
maybe that's why he's the boogeyman yeah
people leave in the boogeyman um
sometimes you know you'll find yourself
in some weird house at that moment or
time in the street or something the
weather is a certain way the lights fall
in a certain way you're walking and then
you're like man there's some wacky
things around here somewhere do you
believe in spirits then there is
something out there don't you
I don't know no actually just so like
there's a spirit there's a mini book I
saw a spirit no I do believe in Djibouti
though I think they just Hey now John
wig needs to relax
he just seems really intense so I'm
curious I'm trying to relax you try self
what why do you chill how do you relax
after a long day uh read um rods
motorcycles go to dinner hang out with
friends nice yeah you watching Netflix
now you're going to be watching up
Netflix yeah yeah I'm a subscriber I go
on there once in a while did you show up
to the bowl and it's going to be honest
I tango actually really sorry what do
you do for Valentine's Day Valentine's
Day coming out Allen tines Jay I know
yet I'm gonna be I'm gonna be travelling
I think so I'm gonna be out of town so
hopefully I don't know what I'm going to
be doing
congratulations on the film I appreciate
the again first you take yes